bien mes chers collègues nous entendons
ce matin en application du cinquième
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution Monsieur Jean-François
delfrecy candidat proposé par le
Président de la République à la
présidente du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique pour les sciences de
la vie et de la santé plus couramment
appelé CCN cette audition sera suivie
d'un vote sur cette candidature pour
lequel vous le savez aucune délégation
nette admise je vous précise que cette
audition fera l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat et consultable
en vidéo à la demande conformément
principe de publicité prévu par la loi
du 23 juillet 2010 je vous rappelle que
le comité est créé en 1983 a vu ses
missions élargir au fil du temps il est
chargé de donner des avis sur les
problèmes éthiques et les questions de
société soulevées par les progrès de la
reconnaissance dans les domaines de la
biologie de la médecine de la santé ou
par les conséquences sur la santé des
progrès de la connaissance dans toute
autre domaine et il doit exercer sa
mission en toute indépendance de plus il
est chargé d'organiser le débat d'un
chargé d'organiser le débat public sous
forme d'État généraux qui doivent
précéder tout projet de réforme sur les
problèmes éthiques et les questions de
société le président et les 45 autre
membres du comité sont nommés pour une
durée de trois ans renouvelable une fois
alors monsieur delphrétise je vous
propose de débuter cette audition par un
propos liminaire dans lequel vous nous
exposerez votre parcours professionnel
en particulier les actions que vous avez
déjà conduites à la tête du CCNE ainsi
que la vision que vous avez de votre
prochain mandat à la présidence du
comité le cas échéant Philippe mouiller
vous posera ensuite quelques questions
en qualité de rapporteur pour cette
audition et les membres de la commission
pour ensuite vous interroger à leur tour
monsieur le professeur vous avez la
parole
bonjour la présidente bonjour mesdames
messenatrices Messieurs les sénateur
très rapidement me présenter je suis
professeur d'immunologie numérique à
Paris Saclay à l'Assistance publique à
Paris au Kremlin-Bicêtre
j'étais toujours un spécialiste de
l'interaction entre le système
immunitaire et les virus donc entre
l'immunologie et la virologie
j'étais amené dans mes fonctions d'abord
essentiellement hospitalières je suis
souvent que je suis un bébé sida avec
beaucoup de cheveux blancs
j'ai été amené à diriger l'Agence
nationale de recherche sur le sida et
les hépatides virales puis à m'occuper
des bolas puis comme vous le savez à
apprendre la direction du comité
scientifique covid-19 auprès du
président de la République
au niveau du CCN j'étais nommé par le
président François Hollande en 2018
et puis renouveler ensuite par par le
président Emmanuel Macron au cours des
derniers mandats
je voudrais discuter avec vous cinq
points autour du CCNE le premier point
et vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente le CCNE était créé par
François Mitterrand en 83 à la suite
vous le savez de
la naissance de d'Amandine avec Lama en
fait c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça et on l'a rappelé d'ailleurs dans le
livre des 40 ans du CCSE je vous ai
adressé je pense à tous
et il y avait eu une vraie volonté à ce
moment-là de réflexion autour de la
vision de la recherche en France et des
interactions de la construction de
l'éthique
au niveau de la recherche
au cours des dernières années le CCNE
vous l'avez aussi rappelé à évoluer avec
d'une part
les états généraux de la bioéthique que
nous avons mené en 2018 pour préparer la
loi de bioéthique il y a eu la loi de
biotique que vous avez votée en août
2021 qui élargit les du CCNE sur un
certain nombre de thématiques et en
particulier sur des aspects d'éthique et
d'environnement et qui modifient aussi
la la composition du CCNE avec l'arrivée
à l'intérieur du ccné de représentants
de la société civile puis ensuite on a
eu les 40 ans du CCNE que nous avons
fêté donc en mars 2023 et à l'occasion
duquel nous avons au sein du CCNE édité
à Lille sur 40 ans de bioéthique en
France que je vous avais fait passer et
qui a permis de d'interroger aussi les
autorités sur quelle vision du CCE pour
les années qui viennent
alors quelle vision en effet pour le
CCNE c'est mon deuxième point pour les
années qui viennent alors je les ai
rappelé lors des 40 ans et je vais vous
les redonner là maintenant
quatre grands points
le premier point c'est bien sûr le l'ADN
du CCNE c'est-à-dire comment l'évolution
de la science une évolution qui est
permanente et je suis vous l'avez bien
compris quelqu'un issu de de
l'innovation et de la recherche
et donc très sensible à ce point qui qui
comporte en effet tous c'est autour de
la nouvelle génomique mais aussi des
nouvelles neurosciences mais aussi des
organoïdes enfin il y a toute une série
de sciences en mouvement qui va poser
qui pose déjà un certain nombre de
questions éthiques majeurs qui vont
continuer donc à se poser
le deuxième point est
issu des modifications de la société
civile c'est un point qui est rentré de
façon assez forte au CCNE notre société
vous avez changé j'ai changé au cours
des 30 ou 40 dernières années et donc
jusqu'à quel point les modifications de
la société civile qui se posent un
certain nombre de questions qui ne sont
pas directement issues des de la science
mais des progrès et des applications de
la science par exemple sur la
procréation mais pas que par exemple sur
d'autres sujets
interrogent-ils et postent-ils un
certain nombre de questions éthiques et
ces sujets je dirais autour de santé
sociétés sont devenus assez prévenants
au sein du cgne si je si je regarde les
derniers avis par exemple à la fois sur
les migrants sur les aspects de la prise
en charge des personnes âgées sur un
certain nombre de situations sur le
consentement c'est donc une série
d'exemples qui sont importants puis il y
a deux nouveaux sujets qui arrivent en
force
euh le premier autour de santé
environnement
ce sont des mondes évidemment c'est des
sujets auxquels vous êtes très sensible
ce sont des mondes qui ne se connaissent
pas je ne se connaissent pas le monde à
la fois de la recherche le monde des ONG
le monde des acteurs c'est des silos en
France vraiment ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans d'autres pays européens
ou il existe des communautés qui ceux
qui se qui sont en parallèle et pourtant
on sait que la santé a un impact sur
l'environnement et que les modifications
évidemment de l'environnement on impact
sur la santé on vous y êtes plus
sensible probablement parce que c'est
cette commission mais la santé on dit
que la production carbone en France est
liée par exemple pour entre c'est
difficile à chiffrer bien sûr mais 10 à
11% liés à la production liée à la santé
à une structure hospitalière notre
organisation autour de la santé que
jusqu'à maintenant c'est des questions
qui ne s'étaient pas posées donc nous
sommes en train de monter un groupe de
travail avec difficulté d'ailleurs
autour de ce sujet mais à mon avis ça
sera un sujet important pour les années
qui viennent et enfin le dernier point
et le numérique et l'intelligence
artificielle et la santé vous le savez
lors des 40 ans le président de la
République a souhaité qu'on aille vers
une autonomie du du comité pilote du
numérique qu'on m'avait confié de mettre
en place et c'est une des choses donc
qui a été faite au sein du CCN lors des
dernières années c'est une révolution
c'est on est voilà il y a une autre
médecine qui est en train de débuter
avec l'IA et le numérique donc on va
créer là dans les mois qui viennent et
c'était aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle je poursuis aussi cette mission
de créer de façon additionnelle parce
que je sais bien que l'ambiance n'est
pas à créer des structures et qu'on
s'est interrogé s'il fallait faire un
grand CCNE avec des piliers ou au
contraire si on allait vers deux
structures l'une à côté de l'autre il
fallait passer par la loi une nouvelle
loi de bioéthique ça nous paraissait
très loin donc on a créé pour l'instant
de structure pour l'une à côté de
l'autre mais étroitement liée avec des
membres qui sont qui vont être partagés
on aura la même administration le même
les mêmes locaux et c'est un des enjeux
de la constitution de ce comité
d'éthique du numérique alors pour ça on
a différents partenaires
bien sûr les autres comités d'éthique et
en particulier des grands organisateurs
cherchent de l'Inserm du CNRS avec
lequel on organise deux grandes réunions
par an et on partage voilà on n'est pas
il y a des choses qui savent mieux faire
que nous et il y a des grands points
qu'on peut qu'on peut aborder et puis
j'y reviendrai il y a bien sûr tout ce
qui est autour des espaces éthiques
régionaux alors
de trois points mais qui vont être plus
rapide je vous rassure
c'est un CCNE en mouvement que je vous
propose si vous me redoublez dans cette
dans cette mission d'abord parce que ça
me ça me ressemble et puis ensuite parce
que c'est c'est une vraie question c'est
à dire de ne pas rester avec un cavité
d'éthique qui est figé il est figé sur
de grandes valeurs et ces grandes
valeurs on doit les conserver elles sont
essentielles un Comité national
d'éthique n'est pas là pour dire ce
qu'il faut faire ou ne pas faire
l'éthique n'est pas la morale mais il y
a un certain nombre de grandes valeurs
qui sont totalement fondamentales et
puis par ailleurs vous avez la société
qui bouge comme je l'ai indiqué et donc
comment on arrive à avoir une ligne de
crête entre à la fois garder les grandes
valeurs et puis tenir compte des
évolutions de la société on ne vit plus
à Paris en province de la même façon
qu'on vivait il y a une cinquantaine
d'années
le deuxième point de ce CNR mouvement
c'est que c'est un CCE ouvert donc sur
la société mais ouvert sur les
territoires et c'est quelque chose qui
auquel je suis sensible quand je suis
arrivé au CCSE je pensais qu'on était
trop club d'intellectuel du 7e
arrondissement et qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait sortir de là d'où une politique
très active avec les espaces éthiques
régionaux douleurs implication dans les
états généraux de la bioéthique tout
leur implication là dans le vous l'avez
vu dans le débat national autour de la
fin de vie où on a organisé la durant
les trois premiers mois de l'année 2023
plus de 320 réunions en région
d'information à des degrés divers
organisés par les espaces éthiques
régionaux qui sont pour nous l'éthique
du terrain qui nous qui nous font
remonter un certain nombre de
questionnements de adressés par la
société et qui permettent de nous
remettre je dirais un peu de sortir de
la tête dans les étoiles que nous sommes
parfois et de nous remettre sur des
questions qu'attendent les citoyens et
puis le troisième point c'est
l'ouverture difficile mais absolument
nécessaire vers les jeunes nous
organisons de une journée des lycéens la
troisième journée des 40 ans qui relie
la semaine prochaine aura lieu sur avec
à l'Assemblée nationale avec plus de 200
jeunes lycéens sur les sujets autour de
santé environnement
j'ai demandé à la suite d'une réunion
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale actuelle qui me semble plus
ouvert que le précédent sur ce sujet sur
l'ouverture
d'un certain nombre de questionsnements
sur les grandes valeurs dans dans notre
système éducatif qui existe dans le
byangle section qui n'existe pas
suffisamment en France et je me battrai
vraiment sur ce point là
alors pour terminer deux points mais
peut-être que vous me posez cette
question donc je les anticipe un peu
avant
le CCNE une institution indépendante
c'est quoi la dépendance quand on
dénommé par le Président de la
République c'est une bonne question ça
ou quand on est nommer à la suite de
votre décision
et au risque de vous surprendre je vais
mettre l'indépendance à deux niveaux
l'indépendance d'une part vis-à-vis du
politique des politiques de la décision
politique mais l'indépendance aussi
vis-à-vis de la société
alors la dépendance vis-à-vis de
politique vous la comprenez facilement
et on voit bien comment est-ce que c'est
pas la courroie d'une décision du prince
et on voit bien l'ensemble des questions
qui peuvent se poser j'essaierai de vous
donner quelques éléments un autre point
que vous voyez moins bien probablement
c'est l'indépendance vis-à-vis de la
société jusqu'à quel point les demandes
de la société les évolutions de la
société dont je vous ai parlé
précédemment et qui sont absolument
d'abord c'est un fait deuxièmement elles
sont nécessaires mais troisièmement
jusqu'à quel point
interfellent-elles avec les questions
que se pose le CCNE et très clairement
au cours des 10 dernières années donc
c'est pas seulement mes mandats mais
avant nous avons posé un certain nombre
de questions sur santé sociétés plus que
sur les avancées de la science donc il y
a il y a bien jusqu'à quel point
finalement les besoins de la société les
désirs de la société autour de la pro
autour de la fin de vie jusqu'à quel
point doivent-ils être pris en compte
par le CCN alors sur la dépendance il y
a quelques éléments de réponse d'abord
moi je connais pas plus indépendant que
des médecins et des chercheurs en France
mais le CCNE vous le savez composé aussi
de juristes de philosophes et de gens de
sciences humaines et sociales le
deuxième élément c'est qu'on peut s'auto
saisir et si on sait s'auto saisie d'une
question on traite les questions qu'on a
envie de saisir puis troisièmement le
CCNE est un lieu d'intelligence
collective assez rare moi j'ai pas mal
roulé ma bosse vous le savez c'est un
lieu d'écoute c'est un lieu où on
s'interroge on arrive avec une idée et
on modifie son idée en écoutant les
autres et donc cet exercice de
construction collective fait que le
dérapage par rapport à une ce qui serait
une demande politique peut-être rattrapé
par les autres
alors après on a dit un impact des avis
qui est variable certains avis sont très
importants et sont repris d'autres moins
par exemple notre avis sur migrants
notre avis sur les l'accès aux
innovations thérapeutiques et pourtant
un problème majeur on fait des bides
totaux de sur à la fois vis-à-vis de
nous probablement mais aussi de la
presse et du grand public et puis on a
des avis
récents par exemple sur le 139 autour de
la fin de vie en septembre 2022 autour
des enjeux éthiques de l'art
construction du système de santé qui ont
un impact assez immédiat sur un certain
nombre de décisions qui sont de nature
de nature politique voilà donc pour
terminer je dirais que le CCNE s'inscrit
aussi et on a monté une réunion qui a
lieu trois ou quatre fois par an avec
les différents grands acteurs en France
de la démocratie on sentait de
sociopolitation puisque certains d'entre
vous et je vous comprends dit que de la
démocratie c'est vous qui êtes la
démocratie mais la démocratie
participative ou social participation de
la construction quand même qui est
important de ce fameux triangle entre
citoyens expertise et décision politique
on le voit sur certains grands sujets ça
permet de débrouiller les choses avant
que vous vous en empariez d'un point de
vue législatif le CCNE c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à cœur c'est clair
c'est engagé là-dessus et nous
réunissons trois ou quatre fois par an
le CESU la Défenseur des droits et puis
un certain le CNS un certain nombre de
collègues pour avoir une réflexion
globale de comment se construit la
démocratie en santé en France donc voilà
et après on peut probablement encore
mieux faire encore que avec notre
nouvelle secrétaire général Ingrid qui
caillasse qui m'accompagne aujourd'hui
ça soit de nos enjeux de la vision
française de lac de la de l'éthique à la
française au niveau international et
quelque chose qui nous tient très à
coeur on a organisé
le colloque européen l'an dernier est
l'occasion de la présidente française de
l'Europe on a des réunions tripartites
avec les Anglais les Allemands on est en
train d'ouvrir ça sur la francophonie
voilà voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
excusez-moi j'étais un peu
de la parole au rapporteur de cette
audition Villiers et ensuite
les questions des collègues merci madame
le Président merci professeur pour votre
présentation et puis surtout votre
regard sur les axes de développement du
système ou d'évolution alors moi j'ai
plusieurs plusieurs questions la
première un petit peu atypique là vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans une démarche pour
exercer un quatrième mandat à la
présidence moi je vais avoir votre avis
sur le grand principe généraux de
limitation du nombre de mandats c'est un
débat connu au niveau du Parlement donc
je voulais avoir votre avis sur ce sujet
là voilà et en même temps vos fonctions
de prendre de conseils de scientifiques
ne risquait-elle pas d'altérer
l'apparence d'indépendance du système
voilà les deux fonctions le CPE comme
l'a dit a fêté ses 40 ans en mars
correspondez-vous aux critiques
consistant à dire que loin de rappeler
des valeurs morales intangibles qui font
obstacle à certaines pratiques le CCNE
finit par cautionner tôt ou tard ce qui
est techniquement possible
voilà je voulais avoir votre regard sur
ce qui nous a pu constater que
pensez-vous du rapport de la convention
citoyenne et de l'aviron du hier par le
16e sur laide active à mourir et d'une
façon générale en matière de méthode
concernant ce débat nous avons vu qu'il
y a eu beaucoup d'acteurs beaucoup de
groupes de travail donc il y a des
groupes de travail du gouvernement les
organes du Parlement le CCN le 16e des
instants sadocs la commence au citoyenne
plein d'acteurs qui ont émis des avis et
à travers tout ça parfois certains avis
et bien viennent se télescopter dans la
période donc moi je voulais avoir votre
avis concernant la légitimité que
peuvent s'exprimer à chacune des
occasions ces différents organismes
quelle est la place du CCNE dans ce
paysage et puisque finalement la
solution face à un nombre d'acteurs
importants et cette complexité en
matière démocratie n'était pas tout
simplement de revaloriser la centralité
de l'activité parlementaire
je remercie
c'est c'est des commentaires un peu
chaud
sur les mandats c'est vraiment une très
bonne question que je me suis posé parce
que j'avais demandé que lors de la
révision de la loi bioéthique que vous
avez votée en août 2021 le mandat du
président de du CSE soit porté de deux
fois trois ans
alors que là jusqu'à maintenant il était
complètement ouvert alors vous allez me
dire et vous et bien moi je me trouve
dans une situation où j'étais à la fois
l'Ancien Régime le nouveau régime etc et
où donc en fait j'ai la possibilité
c'est pas moi qui l'ai qu'il est de
demander de me laisser le secrétaire
général du gouvernement qui a compte
tenu de ma position avant et de
l'arrivée de bioéthique dit qu'il y
avait la possibilité que que je
renouvelle ce mandat de là vous dire que
je ferai deux fois trois ans comme on me
l'a proposé la réponse est non
évidemment je voudrais boucler comme je
voulais indiquer deux trois points qui
m'apparaissent importants l'installation
du comité nationale du numérique et de
l'intelligence artificielle peut-être
certains aspects autour de la fin de vie
j'y reviendrai et puis sans le vouloir
dans la nouvelle loi de bioéthique
le renouvellement des membres du CCNE
est devenu quelque chose tous les trois
ans
qui a un côté sain de renouveler les
choses mais qui est assez difficile à
mettre en oeuvre et par exemple là nous
avons un renouvellement le 31 juillet de
entre 12 et 14 membres du CCNE et chaque
renouvellement de membres du CCNE et
celui-là en particulier remet en
question voyez non non pas le fond du
CCNE mais créer une période un peu
complexe en plus les nominations vous
savez en France prennent un peu plus de
temps qu'on ne veut bien le croire il y
a des trous dans la raquette qui peuvent
se faire donc voilà les voilà ce que je
peux vous indiquer après je après je me
sens en pleine forme mais
mais pas pour faire l'ensemble des
mandats
le deuxième le deuxième point sur
l'indépendance oui vous avez raison je
vous ai répondu enfin j'avais anticipé
cette question si je peux dire c'est une
question que je me pose en permanence
je
vous ai donné les éléments en vous
indiquant que c'était pas seulement
l'indépendance vis-à-vis du politique
mais vis-à-vis de la société et qu'on
avait des éléments à faire valoir qui
sont en particulier l'auto-saisine et
que nous ne sommes que consultatif et
heureusement que nous ne sommes que
consultatif après tout les autorités
vous-même le cceme bon ça c'est une
goutte d'eau et puis inversement c'est
pas tout à fait une goutte d'eau et donc
c'est c'est là où se construit en effet
la réflexion assez originale en France
d'un lieu d'écoute et de création
d'intelligence collective alors est-ce
que le fait d'avoir été président du
conseil scientifique covid-19 me rend
moins indépendant que d'autres
je sais pas parce que je me suis posé la
même question quand j'étais vous savez
pour beaucoup d'entre vous m'a écouté 40
fois un sur au moment du covid sur
sur les relations entre un président
d'un conseil scientifique et les
autorités moi il me semble que le
conseil scientifique en tout cas on a
pensé d'emblée là aussi puisque il y
avait on pouvait s'auto saisir on était
aussi dans mes par le gouvernement nous
étions des médecins et des scientifiques
on pouvait écrire ce qui était fait
certains d'entre vous vont dire qu'on a
été très proche du pouvoir etc je peux
vous dire que sur certains sujets on
était loin d'être très proche du pouvoir
donc voilà je pense que je me suis mis
en débord pendant la période la plus
difficile entre mars 2020 et le mois de
décembre 2020 de la présidente du CCNE
et c'était la vice-présidente qui avait
pris qui avait pris la présidence
c'était la première fois que ça se
produisait de ce type et après il m'a
semblé qu'on a qu'on a reconstruit
complètement
le CCN les valeurs je ne peux que
d'accord avec vous c'est alors après qui
est un certain nombre de personnes
et nous sommes une belle démocratie en
France et je respecte ces
l'ensemble de ces commentaires qui
peuvent être faits
mais voilà c'est des valeurs auxquelles
je tiens à titre personnel à titre
culturel en tant que médecin
mais je constate aussi qu'il y a une
évolution de notre société et une
évolution aussi d'un certain nombre
d'aspects scientifiques alors est-ce que
le CCNE dit toujours oui la réponse est
non la réponse est non sur la GPA on a
été c'est une ligne rouge très claire
sur la constitution d'embryon c'est une
des questions majeures qui va se poser
je vous la mets sur la table aujourd'hui
vous y réfléchirez c'est qu'à partir des
organoïdes c'est à dire de cellules
souches que nous pouvons prendre non pas
à partir de d'embryon mais à partir de
notre peau surtout chez les plus jeunes
on peut cesser le souche leur donner une
direction pour remplacer une hanche ou
un myocarde c'est la thérapeutique de
médecine de demain de médecine du futur
et on peut aussi les orienter pour aller
vers se transformer en gamète mâle ou en
gamètes femelles et ensuite constituer
un embryon dénovo en dehors de sexualité
et et
de combinaison même
à partir de cellules souches d'origine
d'un homme vous rendez compte la bascule
dans laquelle cette pour le CCNE c'est
fondamentalement pris parti et engagé
sur sur ce type de sujet en disant non
là c'est une ligne rouge pour la santé
alors Véronique Guillotin ensuite Annick
Jacquemin Brigitte Michel meunier
Véronique Guillotin merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur professeur voilà moi
j'ai déjà une remarque et peut-être un
élément de satisfaction de d'entendre
effectivement les orientations du CCNE
sur un CCN en mouvement et ouvert sur
les territoires je pense que quand on a
vécu la crise covid comme on l'a vécu et
tous les fantasmes qui ont pu s'exprimer
je crois qu'il est aujourd'hui important
effectivement d'aller au plus près de
nos territoires et vous avez parlé de la
jeunesse donc je pense que là-dessus
c'est une bonne chose effectivement
d'amener les gens et les jeunes
notamment à réfléchir sur les évolutions
de notre société
ensuite il y a un axe enfin ou deux
c'est l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement et tous ces progrès alors
j'ai du mal à vous voir j'ai du mal à
parler quand je vais
voilà j'ai du mal à rigoure avec non
mais comme ça je vais mettre comme ça
voilà on voit bien qu'on a une société
qui est dans une profonde transformation
qu'elle soit démographie mais surtout
technologique on voit arriver
l'intelligence artificielle moi je
m'interroge un peu sur
enfin le CCNE aura des choses évidemment
à dire éventuellement des lignes rouges
à mettre mais est-ce qu'on n'est pas un
moment donné complètement débordé par
ses évolutions qui vont bien plus vite
que les avis que l'on peut rendre enfin
je prends juste l'exemple du chat GBT
par exemple qui qui aujourd'hui nous
nous dépasse et voilà donc comment vous
voyez les choses vous vis-à-vis de ces
évolutions vous en avez un petit peu
parlé pour les cellules souches mais je
pense que pour l'intelligence
artificielle demain l'évolution des
métiers ça va avoir on va être confronté
au même au même difficultés ou en tout
cas au même problématique et puis sur la
One Elf vous avez un peu évoqué
l'environnement et la production
de la production de CO2 et de l'atteinte
de l'environnement par notre autre
production du système de santé je pense
qu'effectivement bon ça c'est pas une
question mais c'est un sujet sur lequel
que ce soit enfin en tout cas le système
de santé en général doit normalement
se poser les bonnes questions et en tout
cas tenter de faire les mêmes efforts
que que la société tout entière
dans votre troisième point concernant
l'orientation que vous voulez donner à
vous parler de l'ouverture sur les
jeunes et notamment les amener à
réfléchir sur les différents sujets de
la société
que pensez-vous de
l'enseignement ou du non-enseignement
qui est fait dans les lycées dans les
collèges
puisque je crois qu'il y a entre 13 et
15% seulement de d'établissements
scolaires qui pratiquent cet
enseignement sur la vie affective ou on
l'appellera comment voudra ou la
sexualité
d'autant que je fais partie de la DDF la
délégation des droits aux femmes et à
l'égalité homme-femme et la DDF a
produit un rapport sur la pornographie
qui met en avant quand même que deux
tiers des enfants de 15 ans et un tiers
des enfants de 9 ans allait
régulièrement sur ces sites porno et
leur modifier complètement leur vision
alors voilà est-ce que vous pouvez
intervenir à ce sujet là pour qu'un peu
plus de de ces établissements scolaires
mettent en place ces enseignements où
vous voyez ça différemment merci bien
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais revenir sur la fin de vie
l'aide active à mourir aussi était une
ligne rouge très claire qui était
décidée par le tracé par le CCNE
aujourd'hui
et ensuite Bernard oui merci même la
présidente monsieur le Président
delfresci merci le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique moi j'ai eu pendant
quelques années l'occasion de
d'y aller de le connaître et donc à
l'occasion des 40 ans je suis ici
monsieur delfresci
là ici non parce que je vois votre
regard voilà j'ai donc entendu des
points d'étape fort intéressant fort
important avec des
des personnages connus des personnalités
qui étaient déjà et qui sont restés donc
il y a une certaine permanence quand
même dans le comité d'éthique et j'ai
beaucoup apprécié cette façon de
construire les avis vous l'avez dit on
arrive parfois avec pas forcément
d'idées claire et autour de la table et
en groupe et avec aussi la durée la
permanence des réunions la constitution
de pensée plus construites plus
collective et on arrive à des avis des
avis qui sont toujours très balancés et
il se trouve que dernièrement donc j'ai
lu avec intérêt celui sur la fin de vie
mais aussi
les mois passés les années passées sur
la procréation et une technique de
procréas pour création médicalement
assistée et il y a toujours un point de
vue d'un côté mais de l'autre côté et ça
je trouve ça très intéressant mais
est-ce que vous pensez pas que parfois
ça les limites dans l'exercice et la
question de ma collègue juste avant
c'est vrai qu'à la lecture de cet avis
on peut se demander en quoi le CCNE
enfin à bouger sur cette ligne là de
puis les deux précédents à vie me
semble-t-il de mémoire qu'il y avait eu
sur le sujet donc voilà donc c'est c'est
à la fois une reconnaissance de la très
grande qualité dans la permanence de la
réflexion mais est-ce que parfois
l'exercice n'a pas des limites
concrètes et puis vous avez parlé de la
perspective de qu'est-ce qui vous reste
à faire en pointant sur le côté santé
environnement je pense que oui notamment
c'est un sujet le numérique vous l'avez
aussi abordé vous y travaillez peut-être
plus concrètement mais voilà donc
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me répondre
que si je vous demande quelle est la
différence de la différence du CCN
d'aujourd'hui avec le CCNE de 2014 2018
et pour terminer Bernard Chaumier merci
madame la Présidente d'abord je voudrais
vous faire écho-propos du rapporteur de
Philippe mouillé dire que la question
qui pose sur les mandats évidemment
dissociés de la personne c'est une
question qui est récurrente qu'on se
pose tous auquel on apporte d'ailleurs
des réponses qui peuvent être
différentes quel que soit le dire le
côté politique de l'hémicycle on est
tous partagés sur cette question là
voilà
je voulais vous remercier pour vos
propos qui sont comme d'habitude tout à
fait intéressant et dresse des
perspectives passionnantes et revenir
sur le contenu des avis du CCNE Michel
meunier vient d'en reparler
à la lumière de celui que vous avez
rendu sur la fin de vie moi je l'ai lu
relu et relu enfin le dernier évidemment
je l'ai lu le trans139 merci Michel Lure
lui est relu
et on peut le lire le lire lire et le
relire de plusieurs façons différentes
et donc il est
rédigé d'une façon extrêmement habile
qui prête à de multiples interprétations
alors c'est
je me suis dit fais la réflexion que
après tout le CCN déposé ses éléments en
réflexion dans la main des législateurs
qui vont devoir se prononcer et qu'au
fond et ben très bien chacun épuisera ce
qu'il veut épuiser et bon par moment
j'ai lu l'affirmation de principes
éthiques mais aussi l'affirmation que
ces principes devaient être mis au
regard de la réalité donc il pouvait
être interprété différemment
par exemple et j'en ai parlé dans lors
d'une audition précédente vous posez
vous semblez poser mais vous avez
peut-être nous infirmer ma lecture dès
qu'on décisionnalités très strictes
d'ouverture de l'aide active à mourir
conditionnalités concernant une réelle
application de l'accès aux soins de
palliatifs de nos concitoyens et vous
semblez indiquer dans votre avis que
c'est une condition de l'ouverture de
l'aide active à mourir or nous savons
tous dans cette salle que dans 5 ans la
situation sera probablement
pas extrêmement meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
en tout cas il y aura toujours beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui n'auront pas
accès aux soins palliatifs ne serait-ce
que pour des questions de formation de
nombre de professionnels etc etc et donc
évidemment comme comme toute réflexion
éthique ne peut être délié de la réalité
de son effectivité on peut lire votre
avis comme les conditions ne sont pas
remplies d'ouverture de l'aide active à
mourir donc voilà je suis comme de mes
collègues l'ont expliqué à la fois
toujours passionné par vos avis certains
traces très clairement une ligne éthique
et le mode d'application et d'autres
comme sur l'aide active à mourir nous
laisse plus perplexe donc est-ce que
vous pourriez nous éclairer sur ce que
vous souhaitez faire passer comme
message à la société certainement mais
en tout cas la législateur puisque c'est
nous qui allons devoir délibérer je
remercie merci professeur delfacés
une petite question
alors si je reprends un peu dans l'ordre
votre réflexion sur les territoires oui
bien sûr je ne peux que partager cette
cette vision
pour être bien clair donc les espaces
éthiques régionaux vous les en avez dans
chaque grande région française
ils ont ils sont financés par le
ministère de la Santé
ils sont ouverts sur des questions
autour de l'éthique en santé et on pense
d'ailleurs utiliser ce réseau aussi pour
les ouvrir sur les enjeux du numérique
et de l'intelligence artificielle
ils ont mis un certain temps avant de se
je dirais de se mettre en route de
trouver leur positionnement au niveau
des territoires il existe différentes
autres structures il y a les il y a les
CRSA il y a et mais on l'a bien vu je
dirais que à l'occasion à la fois des
états généraux de la bioéthique et on
vient de le voir comme je l'ai rappelé à
l'occasion du débat sur la fin de vie et
sur d'autres sujets ils ont fait par
exemple avec le comité éthique de
l'Inserm une vraie réflexion
sur les enjeux de la génomique donc
indépendamment du CCNE donc qui sont
bien nous sommes bien il n'y a aucune
sentiment de dépendance le CCED n'est
pas pour donner des ordres aux horaires
mais au contraire c'est dans un
accompagnement auquel je tenais beaucoup
moi d'aller vers les territoires puisque
certains d'entre vous le savent je suis
un faux parisien et je tiens beaucoup à
cette vision de ce qui peut se passer
dans nos territoires alors sur les sur
les
je dirais il faut que vous sachiez aussi
que cette vision de réseau que nous
avons en France et regardez avec des
yeux ronds et avec beaucoup d'envie sur
l'organisation des États généraux par
les la communauté internationale de
par exemple à la fois sur ce triptyque
très particulier que nous avons France
avec un CCNE la loi de bioéthique qui
sont deux choses qui se qui se parlent
entre elles et puis maintenant cette
ouverture vers les territoires par
exemple le Japon est en train de vouloir
construire quelque chose du même type et
j'étais amené après les états généraux
de la bioéthique et avant le et avant la
crise covid à aller présenter ce qui
était un peu le modèle français de
construction de de la bioéthique
numérique voilà alors est-ce qu'on est
déjà trop tard je ne sais pas si on est
trop tard là aussi c'est le premier
comité d'éthique du numérique qui va
être créé en Europe
on peut toujours les Français on se tire
toujours une balle dans le pied en
disant on fait pas bien c'est pas
terrible et cetera bon voilà c'est le
premier comité d'éthique du numérique
qui va être créé en Europe dans les
grandes démocraties aux États-Unis ils
ont des comités d'éthique et au Canada
en particulier du numérique dans les
grandes universités Sada dire un an donc
on n'a pas énormément de retard
je suis moi
fasciné et inquiet de ce qui est en
train de se passer en effet autour de
la possibilité numérique chaque GPT bien
sûr mais vous avez vu maintenant sur en
radiologie ce que c'est en train de
devenir je lisais hier je découvrais
hier que que voilà
certains logiciels sont plus efficaces
que 20 ans de transplanteur alors que
les transplanteurs sont des gens qui
connaissent super bien leur boulot qui
ont qui ont vu arriver l'immunologie de
pointe et bien qu'un logiciel permettait
de de mieux suivre et de mieux moduler
l'immunération dans les transplantations
donc on est on est au début d'une vraie
révolution et d'une vraie révolution qui
touche là des métiers hyper
intellectuels donc avec des vrais grands
questionnements de je vous recommande
moi j'ai été très frappé par ces deux
papiers dans le monde il y a de samedi
en 8 des deux inventeurs entre
guillemets de chaque GPT qui avait eu le
l'équivalent du prix Nobel de en
numérique qui porte un autre nom je l'ai
oublié et dont les deux il y a un
français qui a travaillé en Californie
qui profit au Collège de France et
l'autre qui est un Canadien et les deux
après 10 ans il y en a un qui dit on
n'arrête pas la science et ça rejoint
des questions que vous me posez et puis
c'est en train de bouger et l'autre dit
au contraire il faut faire il faut faire
une pause comme on a fait une pause en
génomique et moi je comme ça sur y
compris des espèces santé je me demande
s'il ne faut pas qu'on s'empare de ça
quand on dit on ne peut pas arrêter les
choses si je vous rappelle que le
clonage a tenu l'interdiction de clonage
est tenue l'interdiction d'un certain
nombre de d'utilisation de pratiques en
génomiques avec les modifications chez
l'embryon ont tenu donc on est capable
d'une communauté scientifique à partir
du moment on la stimule qui est capable
de tenir
bon sur les jeunes voilà constat partagé
c'est à la fois dans le squelette mais
je dirais aussi y compris dans les
professions médicales
quand vous regardez ce qui est sur
l'enseignement de l'éthique et des
grandes valeurs dans la majorité de nos
facs de médecine
c'était pas très bon jusqu'à maintenant
les doyages étaient portés beaucoup ça
auprès de la conférence des doyens etc
et comment c'est la même chose que pour
les que pour les jeunes c'est la
construction des programmes c'est un
état dans l'état quand vous êtes un
doyen de médecine vous avez autour de
vous tous vos profs etc qui vous disent
mais non je veux deux heures de plus en
génomique regarde en intelligence
artificielle c'est passionnant ce qui
est enceinte reproduire il faut produire
nos étudiants et du coup les valeurs de
fond
les valeurs qui font que de la médecine
est un métier d'humanité est un métier
d'écoute et pas seulement un métier
technique et ben passe à la trappe alors
je pense qu'on a rattrapé les choses en
médecine là de façon récente la jeune
génération des doyens est beaucoup plus
ouverte sur ces sujets d'humanité c'est
clair mais si vous pouvez pousser si
vous entendez les nouveaux le nouveau
président de la Conférence des doyens
merci beaucoup parce que plus on pousse
plus il réagissent et je pense que ce
qui va ouvrir c'est que les facs de
médecine comme vous le savez sont en
train de disparaître pour entrer dans
des grandes universités et donc les
autres aspects disparaître au plan
administratif j'entends et et donc le
fait d'avoir des sciences humaines et
sociales autour d'elle est un élément
fondamental même chose pour les
programmes de du
primaire enfin ou de ou du secondaire
moi je vois bien mes petits-enfants
quand je leur parle un peu de ça ils me
regardent un peu aussi voilà gentiment
mais
et pourtant et pourtant apprendre à
vivre ensemble
et le faire quand on est gamin c'est un
moment essentiel
mais là aussi voilà
on a eu un rendez-vous avec le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
est très ouvert sur ces sujets mais
qu'est-ce qui peut faire j'ai demandé à
avoir une rendez-vous Avec les recettes
avec les inspecteurs généraux de
l'éducation nationale qui tiennent en
fait les programmes c'est un état dans
l'état bon pour essayer de les
convaincre de ça écoutez souhaitez-moi
bonne chance voilà
sur la fin de vie et les avis du CCNE
les avis du CCNE oui c'est une fois de
plus un exercice d'intelligence
collective
je vous rappelle que dans les avis du
CCNE on peut avoir des positions
minoritaires
et que il n'y a pas forcément on n'est
pas forcément dans un consensus mou où
on essaie de rassembler tout le monde si
on peut c'est bien si on peut pas c'est
pas bien et c'est très bien aussi c'est
la démocratie et sur un certain nombre
de sujets complexes difficiles nous
avons eu des avis minoritaires et c'est
bien qu'on puisse rester avec ses avis
minoritaires
alors sur la fin de vie
[Musique]
est-ce que le CCNE a changé d'avis
pas tout à fait je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec cette remarque si je relis
ce que nous avions écrit après les états
généraux de la bioéthique en septembre
2018 sur un avis du socine qui était
pour éclairer justement pour vous
éclairer sur les grands enjeux qui
allait se poser dans la construction de
la loi de bioéthique nous avions eu un
certain nombre de débats sur la fin de
vie on savait que la fin de vie ne
ferait pas partie de la loi de biotique
mais moi j'avais souhaité que puisqu'on
rassemblé ces grands débats et bien les
citoyens ils ont vite parlé de ça et
nous avions donc évoqué en disant la loi
clef et onety n'est pas très connue ni
appliquée il y a certains nombre de
situations complexes qui posent qui pose
questionnement et qui ne sont pas et qui
ne sont pas résolus par la loi classique
donc ceci avait déjà été évoqué en 2018
et même si je remonte avant
dans des avis dans des avis de mes
prédécesseurs et une fois de plus un
président de CCNE
[Musique]
important alors sur sur la fin de vie
elle-même écoutez nous nous sommes
saisis et j'ai bien compris je suis
assez sensible à ce message de il y a
beaucoup de monde qui a travaillé sur
sur la fin de vie et so what alors
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on retient je
vous rappelle quand même l'historique de
tout ça le CCNE alors que nous étions
encore dans la crise covid en juin 2021
se s'auto saisit du sujet de réflexion
autour de la fin de vie pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait eu déjà deux tentatives de
la part d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale pour
voter à la petite semaine une loi sur la
fin de vie et je n'étais pas d'accord
sur ce fait là c'était un sujet qui
était suffisamment important pour qu'on
prenne le temps de prendre le temps sur
un sujet citoyen qui est majeur pour
nous tous qu'on aille dans une direction
ou qu'on aille vers l'autre et c'est un
sujet qui est d'une très grande
fragilité je vous rappelle les deux mots
clés de notre avis c'est autonomie et
solidarité
autonomie qui est une valeur éthique
fondamentale avec la notion de liberté
individuelle et solidarité qui engage
finalement une vision plus collective de
s'occuper des plus fragiles et c'est
notre c'est un grand principe éthique et
Dieu sait qu'on est dans un élément de
fragilité quand on est en fin de vie
quel qu'en soit son milieu
et donc la vie du CCE comprend quatre
parties je vais bien les résumer pour
essayer de construire ma pensée entre
guillemets là-dessus une première partie
qui fait qui dit très clairement que la
loi cléonetti n'est pas suffisamment
connue ni appliqué
ce qui pose d'ailleurs le problème de
l'évaluation des lois en France et de la
complexité des politiques publiques une
deuxième partie qui dit qu'on peut faire
mieux sur les soins palliatifs quand
j'entends qu'en France on n'a pas bougé
sur les soins palliatifs c'est faux moi
vous n'imaginez pas pour un vieux
médecin comme moi qui a connu la période
SIDA on avait rien on n'avait rien de
rien bon et il y a maintenant dans
l'ensemble des départements des lits de
soins palliatifs il y a des départements
qui n'ont pas d'unité de service de
soins palliatifs mais il y a des dans
tous les départements français y compris
dans les territoires ultramarins vous
avez des lits ou des unités mobiles de
soins palliatifs donc on a on a beaucoup
progressé quand on
met on peut encore mieux faire il manque
encore il y a des besoins quantitatifs
et qualitatifs qui sont importants la
culture palliative n'est pas
suffisamment rentrée autour de à la fois
de nos médecins de nos soignants en
général en dehors bien sûr des des
spécialistes de soins palliatifs bon le
troisième point
a été de dire et si on avait tous ces
moyens
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un certain nombre
de situations
en particulier où le pronostic vital et
réservé à moyen terme par moyen terme
quelques semaines quelques mois quelques
exemples des maladies neurogénaires des
générative de type slam mais pas que ou
des cinquième ligne ou des sixième ligne
de chimiothérapie ou là où il y a une
forme je dirais de d'obstination
déraisonnable à certains moments et so
what de présenter une nouvelle ligne
enfin bon et où là au nom de la dignité
de l'autonomie est-ce que certaines
personnes qui le souhaitent mais ce
n'est pas absolument pas du tout une
obligation évidemment c'est les
personnes c'est les citoyens qui le
souhaitent peuvent-ils avoir accès à une
aide médicale à mourir et le CCNE répond
oui et donc on ouvre dans une certaine
mesure la porte sur le suicide assisté
et non sur le tanasis je peux pas être
plus clair que que qu'aujourd'hui sur
dans des conditions précises qui sont à
définir et on vous passe le bébé pour
définir les conditions entre guillemets
et puis le dernier point j'insiste
là-dessus le CCNE dans son avis et qui
est sorti en septembre
2022 demande qu'on prenne le temps de
prendre le temps et qui a un grand débat
national avec une convention citoyenne
avant que ça revienne vers vous au
niveau du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale et somme toute sur ce point-là
quand vous me disiez l'impact ou la
relation par rapport aux politiques oui
là il y a une il y a une fonction
politique au sens je dirais citoyenne du
socine qui rentre dans la politique de
la cité et qui dit oui c'est un sujet
suffisamment important pour qu'on prenne
le temps et de façon à vous débrouiller
une forme de terrain avant que vous
fassiez ce qu'est la vraie construction
de la loi
et Elisabeth maintenant voulait
compléter
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
professeur c'est toujours passionnant de
vous écouter et puis d'entendre aussi
l'ambition que vous avez pour le CCNE je
voulais m'arrêter juste sur deux points
c'est d'abord vous avez parlé de santé
environnement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est tous sidérés par le changement de
climat l'augmentation de la température
et on pense que les uns les autres il y
aura des conséquences terribles pour
l'être humain est-ce que en particulier
cette question est largement abordée sur
ce point sur comment le numérique j'ai
aussi beaucoup de d'appréhensions parce
que comment essayer de garder cet
équilibre
que ce soit toujours l'humain qui est la
main sur sur
ces cerveaux enfin cette intelligence
artificielle donc ça c'est les deux
points que j'aurais voulu
étendre enfin en tout cas en termes de
de continuité de vos propos je
m'intéresserai aussi à la santé mentale
parce que on l'a vu après le covid
pendant le covid
ça a eu des répercussions cette épidémie
sur les jeunes mais pas que les jeunes
et le fait que l'environnement change
continuellement qu'il y ait la guerre à
la porte de l'Europe qu'il y ait voilà
des des commandes
des fractures très très importantes dans
nos sociétés
ça donne beaucoup d'angoisses et on sent
que certains réagissent par la violence
et d'autres réagissent par l'addiction
de tas de produits et on voit bien que
notre société est très fragile et n'a
pas forcément cette résilience qu'il
faut avoir dans ces périodes où tout
bouge à une rapidité folle et comment le
CCNE peut apporter voilà ses
connaissances en expertise pour aider la
société à affronter finalement toutes
les crises pas seulement sanitaires que
nous aurons à vivre
oui monsieur
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Professeur merci pour vos propos
notamment sur la fin de vie parce que si
vous voulez c'est quand même quelque
chose où il faut être
sur ce sujet intime et complexe comme
vous l'avez dit extrêmement prudent
puisque est-ce que
l'euthanasie ou le fichier d'assister
est un soin et les soignants bien dans
la très grande majorité notamment les
soins palliatifs répondent à 90% non et
ils disent même dans les EHPAD où les
gens ne n'acceptent pas
cela et aussi une expérience dans
certains pays où il y avait 90%
qui
bénéficier de je peux dire de
l'euthanasie ou des fins de vie
notamment dans les Pays-Bas en 2002 et
actuellement si vous voulez pour des
pour des maladies pour des maladies pour
maladies tout à fait extrême où la
personne est en fin de vie à brève
échéant à très brève échéance et
maintenant ils ne sont plus que 60%.
donc il y a quand même une déviance dans
certains pays et donc je suis
effectivement en ce qui me concerne tout
à fait satisfait de de vos propos en ce
qui concerne les soins palliatifs
j'ai lorsqu'il y a eu une réunion de
délégués de la DMD à Paris j'ai entendu
sur
sur RTL
les personnes de la Corrèze qui disaient
que il y avait pas de soins palliatifs
dans le département donc je vais appeler
moi je
j'utilise les soins palliatifs depuis
très longtemps donc j'ai trouvé ça quand
même et en fait ah ben oui mais on m'a
dit ah ben il y a pas de de service de
soins palliatifs mais j'ai dit attendez
il y a des soins palliatifs qui sont une
équipe itinérante qui va dans les EHPAD
qui va à domicile donc ça fonctionne
parfaitement bien si vous voulez donc il
faut faire attention dans ce qui est dit
il y a dans beaucoup de départements
effectivement pas de service spécifique
de soins palliatifs mais il y a des
soins palliatifs itinérants qui rendent
des services absolument formidables
et ensuite ce sera terminé
oui sur va sur ces deux sujets majeurs
qui à mes yeux sont évidemment des
points de
fondamentaux pour la
construction du CCNE là dans les années
qui viennent santé environnement
je rassis sur la difficulté
c'est
en général quand il y a une difficulté
moi je
j'aime bien c'est un challenge plutôt là
je me rends compte de l'extrême
difficulté de rassembler ces communautés
et si le CCNE peut avoir un certain rôle
finalement un rôle je dirais non
implicite mais mais qui peut te se
rapprocher c'est on a de très belles
communautés en santé on a des ONG en
santé on a on a tout un modèle en santé
qui est extrêmement bien construit quoi
qu'on en dise et
sur l'environnement où ils ont construit
cette façon très différente vous avez vu
qu'il y a aussi une forme très de
mélange entre l'expertise et faire
partie du GIEC il y a des contextes
d'une vision scientifique qui est
différente et surtout les ONG elles se
connaissent pas donc l'objet du CCE va
être d'essayer de rassembler dans des
groupes de travail autour de ça et de
poser un certain nombre de de questions
en jeu éthique et de à partir de des
faits que l'on voit autour du
réchauffement elle elles sont trouvables
mais pas si facile que ça ceux qui sont
intéressés je vous recommande alors
c'est pas pour vendre le livre si vous
l'avez déjà mais je vous recommande le
chapitre des 40 ans qui est sur santé
environnement et qui fait bien le point
sur les enjeux éthiques puisque notre
fonction est bien de poser les questions
éthiques autour de santé environnement
sur la santé mentale oui c'est une
grande question écoutée on a un groupe
de travail qui doit rendre la vie je
pense en octobre sur ce sujet en post
covid mais pas seulement parce que vite
c'était plus vieux que ça mais qui doit
rendre un avis sur bon donc vous y
trouverez un certain nombre de de notre
de nos vision
sur fin de vie bon vous y revenez que
vous dire de plus moi j'insiste sur sur
la très grande
humilité
humanitaire
dont on doit tous faire
qui doit nous pousser sur la con sur la
la construction de de ce sujet
au combien intime
où il peut y avoir et vous le savez
d'ailleurs au niveau de chacun de nos
concitoyens plutôt une vision quand on
est en bonne santé une autre vision
quand on n'est pas en très bonne santé
et ensuite même un retour après ça doit
être pleinement parfaitement respecté
qui n'a pas autour de lui vécu des
moments extrêmement difficiles avec des
proches et une fin de vie complexe alors
moi il y a deux points quand même sur
lequel je suis obligé de tout petit peu
de réagir c'est que quand j'entends que
la communauté médicale
est totalement contre tout évolution de
la loi si à la fois vrai il faut c'est
vrai pour les médecins et les soignants
en général puisque après tous les aides
soignantes les infirmières sont aussi
importantes que les médecins sur cet
aspect de fin de vie
et cette communauté des soignants de
soins palliatifs c'est vrai et
majoritairement contre ça c'est vrai
elle peut évoluer
le reste de la communauté médicale c'est
plus nuancé et on le voit bien enfin on
fait pas de la bioéthique sur sur des
statistiques ni des sondages mais c'est
une réalité même si à titre individuel
certains d'entre vous et je sais
beaucoup d'entre vous fait partie de
d'une communauté médicale au sens très
large du terme mais c'est beaucoup plus
lancé je le citais tout à l'heure les
les
oncologues sont sont quand même très
c'est n'oublions pas que la majorité des
personnes qui décèdent dans le système
hospitalier sont issus de l'oncologie
les les
urgentistes les réanimateurs
c'est dans le problème des urgences moi
j'ai dirigé pendant un certain temps les
urgences habissaient avant de reprendre
mais mes visions immunologies biceps le
passage aux urgences est multiplié par 4
par rapport au moment où j'étais donc
c'est extraordinaire et c'est partout
pareil et quand même un des un des
points importants qui n'a pas besoin
d'évolution de la loi mais qui a besoin
qu'on ait une culture éthique autour de
la fin de vie qui se mette en place
c'est typique là où on meurt le plus mal
c'est probablement et où les soins
palliatifs je dirais sont le plus
inaccessibles c'est dans les EHPAD et à
domicile donc il y a un effort
considérable à faire non pas tellement
sur les services hospitaliers qui sont
assez bien ancrés vous avez très bien
résumé les choses mais mais c'est plutôt
voilà c'est c'est une vieille dame où
les pas dit c'est pas notre job de
s'occuper de la fin de vie qu'il envoie
aux urgences et les services
hospitaliers disent mais c'est pas notre
malade on la prend pas et donc elle
reste deux trois quatre quatre jours et
elle finit sa vie dans des conditions
indignes malgré les urgentistes je
dirais et c'est là où il faut tous qu'on
avance donc une utilisation déjà
intéressante de la de des moyens que
nous avons et puis après il y a un
certain nombre de situations et qui
posent la question mais de fond je la
reconnais c'est est-ce que notre mort
nous appartient
où est-ce qu'elle appartient à la
société
et la société la confié
au cours de l'évolution de la société au
corps médical et au corps des soignants
puisque 80% des décès surviennent dans
une structures médicalisées et c'est une
question de fond
intime et où chacun peut évidemment
avoir une vision différente que je
respecte
quelque chose et après
le président merci monsieur le
professeur vous avez été président du
conseil scientifique et évoqué la
situation de covid-19 vous avez indiqué
à l'époque avoir des regrets dans le
cadre la gestion de cette pandémie et
aussi qu'elle allait se propager se
renouveler aujourd'hui on entend
certains médecins et des particuliers
aussi dire que des effets secondaires
sont survenus suite aux diverses
vaccinations alors quel est votre
position aujourd'hui avec ce recul
vous êtes revenu président du conseil
scientifique
je vous rappelle que
le président du conseil scientifique a
terminé là j'ai terminé un mandat vous
voyez que je suis capable de terminer
les mandats et abattement de border
depuis longtemps et vous le savez très
bien je vous l'avais expliqué on a
terminé avec la fin de la loi de crise
sanitaire le 31 juillet 2022 bon donc
c'est presque en off que je vous réponds
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le président du
cca2 qui vous répond écoutez je pense
alors vraiment sur vous savez qu'il
existait un groupe vaccin qui était
piloté par Alain Fisher mais évidemment
je me suis on a été très lié et je me
suis beaucoup intéressé au vaccin et
souvenez-vous je me vois dans une salle
du Sénat sur les vaccins je vous ai dit
deux choses
et dont certaines nous ont surprises et
vous pouvez retrouver mes propos dans
dans je me souviens de la salle du bas
je vous ai dit que les vaccins avaient
probablement une durée de vie beaucoup
plus courte qu'on ne le pensait et qu'on
serait amené à revexiner deux fois trois
fois quatre fois et certains d'entre
vous me regardez comme ça et y compris
le ministre de la Santé à l'époque avait
dit bon c'est la vie du professeur
delfresy
finalement c'était pas mon avis c'était
la vie du conseil scientifique et on
n'avait pas tout à fait tort de penser
que il y avait une durée de vie
relativement limitée des vaccins mais
qui par ailleurs je vous ai dit aussi
qu'il protégeait de façon massive contre
la survenue de forme sévère et de forme
grave et c'est la façon d'ailleurs donc
la France et les grandes démocraties
nous avons gagné dans covid par rapport
aux autocraties et il faut être fier de
ça et j'en suis fier à titre personnel
je vais être très clair là-dessus du
fait qu'on a appris à vivre avec
les virus et les variantes
sur votre question y a-t-il les effets
secondaires des vaccins oui bien sûr
qu'il y a des effets secondaires du
vaccins si vous me connaissez un grand
médicament qui n'a pas d'effets
secondaires vous venez me voir
je l'ai toujours dit
mais ces effets secondaires sont limités
alors si vous me posez la question et
ils n'ont jamais été autant surveillés
par les agences de surveillance et de
biosurveillance que qui ont été mises en
place pas seulement en France mais dans
l'ensemble des grands pays
et on le voit bien les données sortent
là maintenant ce qui sont des
surveillants ce niveau populationnel sur
des sur des dizaines et des dizaines de
millions de personnes oui il y a
quelques effets secondaires alors vous
allez me poser une troisième question
donc j'anticipe qui va être de dire mais
est-ce qu'il y a des effets secondaires
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire que dans
10 ans ou dans 15 ans il y aura pas des
effets secondaires va être des vaccins à
merena je n'en sais rien
je n'en sais rien et si je vous disais
et si je vous disais le contraire il
faudrait pas me croire on n'a pas ce
recul cela dit on a bien sur un certain
nombre de grands médicaments de grands
médicaments avec par exemple sur
l'immunothérapie qui est un domaine que
je connais bien qui a révolutionné entre
guillemets mais quand on simule de façon
massive la réponse immunitaire dans
certains cancers que ces cancers vont
aller bien est-ce que est-ce que on peut
dire comment ils vont être dans 10-15
ans après avoir une simulation
d'anciennes militaire la personne peut
le dire donc vous voyez c'est je pense
qu'il faut ces vaccins très clairement
moi je suis très clair là-dessus on
sortit nos grandes démocraties de
l'impasse dans laquelle nous étions et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je veux
dire on peut vivre avec
très bien merci professeur de cette
audition nous allons vous libérer entre
guillemets
et donc nous allons passer au vote
ensuite
je redis bien que mes derniers propos ne
sont pas ceux du président du CCNE ça
bien été dit et noter
la question était posée au président le
conseil scientifique